how you doing guys today we have a 2017
Dodge Challenger customer lost the only
key so uh we're going to create a key
from scratch we're just going to program
it let's get
started so I'm going to use otel km1 100
I have an aftermarket key that obviously
doesn't work right now we're going to
connect the dungle underneath the
steering column by the way if you like
those videos don't forget to like And
subscribe so you can see my daily
videos so we can have a SE and start
[Music]
programming so we're going to accept the
terms uh just to show the key doesn't
work we're going to go to
immobilizer we're going to choose Dodge
now since the ignition cannot be turned
on I'm going to choose manual
selection I'm going to choose North
America and we're going to find the
Challenger and it's 15 to 17 push to
start smart key make sure that
everything is right and hit yes do you
have a learn key turn ignition on we
don't so we're just going to hit okay
[Music]
when we're in in the main menu we're
going to go to hot
function we're going to do smart key
learning and we're going to start the
procedure it says that we need to erase
the keys first if we want to reprogram
the other ones we're just going to hit
okay there is four keys in the memory
tell me to turn the ignition off and the
hazard lights on so ignition is off
we're just going to turn the hazard
lights we're going to hit
[Music]
okay
now it's going to attempt to read the
PIN code usually takes about 1 to 10
minutes we're going to fast
forward and in about 1 minute uh it it
able to read the PIN
[Music]
code here's our four digigit pin code
I'm going to hit
okay it says to turn on the FL flashers
it's already on make sure the ignition
is off all wireless devices are away and
ask me if I want to learn the next key
I'm going to put the fob next to the
ignition in a second I just hit yes and
now it tells me to hold it near the
proximity and without pushing it uh just
keep it there and hit okay on the
[Music]
machine now we just tell me that
repeatedly
press and release the unlock button so
I'm just going to hold it next to the
start and I'm going to press on it
multiple times until the screen changes
there you
go and it says learn Keys five learning
successful you want an next key I'm
going to hit no please turn on the
emergency flashes they're already on I'm
going to hit
okay and that's it five keys in the
memory so now we can start it let's test
it
out locks and
unlocks
nice and easy everything worked the way
it should we're going to test it from
the outside as
[Music]
well don't forget your
dongle all the buttons should just fine
always want test before we
get thank you very much for watching
don't forget to like And subscribe we'll
see you
next